NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO. CALDERON CARILLO
SERVAN TAZ
TRIAL CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU.
CHOI. KANSEN CHU. COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DAHLE. DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES
SAWYER.
KALRA
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON.
QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
THURMOND AND.
TEEN VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WOOD.
YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY.
TO PLEASE STAND FOR TODAY'S A
VOCATION WHICH WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVENUE OF STUFF IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
TOMORROW WILL BE THE FIFTEEN
DAY.
AND LAST DAY OF THE TRADITIONAL
LUNAR NEW YEAR CELEBRATION.
FOR MOST FIVE MILLENNIA
THROUGHOUT ASIA LUNAR NEW YEAR
HAS BEEN A TIME TO GATHER
TOGETHER WITH FAMILY.
THE CELEBRATION A FIFTEEN DAYS
OFTEN INVOLVED TO A PASSED THE
FORESTS.
THERE WOULD BE PRAYERS AND
CEREMONIES EXPRESSING THE DEEP
WISH FOR HEALTHY AND PROSPEROUS
NEW YEAR.
WHICH A BOUNTIFUL PRIOR TO THE
NEW YEAR. HOMES
WERE CLEAN. SYMBOLICALLY
SWEEPING AWAY BAD LUCK FROM
EVERY NOOK AND CRANNY OF OUR
LIVES.
AFTER THE CLEANING ON NEW YEAR'S
EVE. DOORS AND WINDOWS REMAINED
CLOSE.
TO PREVENT BAD LUCK AND
MISFORTUNE FROM GETTING BACK
INTO THE HOME.
AND ON NEW YEAR'S MORNING THE
DOORS AND WINDOWS WERE OPEN
WIDE.
TO ALLOW THE FRESHNESS OF THE
NEW YEAR'S GOOD FORTUNE.
IFILL EACH HOME.
THERE WAS A SENSE OF STARTING
WITH A CLEAN SLATE.
A NEW BEGINNING.
BUT WE KNOW. IN THE FLOW OF TIME
THROUGH ETERNITY.
THERE IS NO BEGINNING AND NO
ENDING.
HUMANITIES MANY CULTURES HAVE
CREATED CALENDARS TO MARK THE
PASSINGOF TIME IT IS INFINITE.
BUT EVERY CALENDAR THAT
HUMANKIND HAS CREATED. AN EVERY
NEW YEAR CELEBRATED SHARES THE
SAME DEEP WISH.
EACH TIME WE CELEBRATE A NEW
YEAR.
WE ARE RENEWING OUR HOPE FOR A
BETTER FUTURE.
AS WE CLOSE THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
CELEBRATION. LET US ALL TRY TO
LIVE THE DAYS AHEAD. WITH THEIR
WISDOM ICE OPEN.
APPRECIATING EACH DAY.
AND MAKING THE MOST OF EVERY
OPPORTUNITY.
TO HELP CREATE A BETTER FUTURE
FOR THE GENERATIONS TO COME.
IN TRYING OUR BEST
CREATED BETTER FUTURE.
WE MAY SOME DAY. BECOME THE
ANCESTORS WORTHY. OF BEING
REMEMBERED.
NOW MORE ME THEM WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND. I INVITE YOU
TO REMAIN STANDING FOR TODAY'S
FLAG SALUTE WILL TO WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHARON QUIRK SILVA.
PLEASE JOIN ME INCLUDING OUR
FLAG I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE FUTILE
AYE. UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
I DO REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS.
MY EDITION CROWD. PHYSICAL.
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
EASILY MET AT NINE AM ON BILL
LAURA FRIEDMAN THIS IS.
PRETEND THAT THEY SIMPLY
PROVIDER HELD AROUND MOVES A
MISTER DALLI SECONDS AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTIONS AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
ALL ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND REPORTED IN TODAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST THIS IS
ME I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS DAVID CHIU. GRAYSON
O'DONNELL AND RESEARCH YOU TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CHEWING GRAYSON WILL HAVE THEIR
DEATHS SEATED. OTHER GUESTS
SEATED AT THEIR DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SPEAKER AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA I AM GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE OF INTENT TO REMOVE ITEM
A THREE. SB ONE THIRTY FOUR
MANDATES FROM THE NECK TO FALL.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
HERE TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS
THEY HUMANA SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO WELCOME. GAS
FROM MY DISTRICT TO THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY I'M PROUD TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THE LITTLE LAKE MIDDLE THAT
LITTLE IT MIDDLE SCHOOL HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL TO WATCH.
JOINING US TODAY ARE GEORGE
BUCHANAN PRESIDENT OF THE LITTLE
LAKE SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION DOOR SANDOVAL WHO IS
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
DOCTOR WILLIAM CREAM THE
SUPERINTENDENT ANNA GUTIERREZ
THE PRINCIPLE OF LAKESIDE MIDDLE
SCHOOL AS WELL AS NATHAN POOL
AND SUSAN REYNOSO WHO ARE BOTH
TEACHERS AT. LITTLE LAKE AYE
LAKESIDE MIDDLE SCHOOL PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING THEM
ON THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENT AND
WELCOMING THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND TODAY PROUD
FATHER TO HAVE MY SON WITH ME
WHO FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS.
HAS SERVED AS A FIRE EXPLORER
FOR CONTRA COSTA FIRE. AND.
WORKING TOWARD ASPIRE SCIENCE
DEGREE AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
GOING INTO THE FIRE ACADEMY I
INTRODUCE YOU JOSEPH GRAYSON.
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THINK YOU AND I
FORGOT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TODAY IS HIS TWENTY FIRST
BIRTHDAY
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR WILL BE
CONTINUED.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM FIVE
HR SEVENTY EIGHT MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SOMEONE MEMBER THURMAN'S
RELATIVE TO READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
MEMBERS TODAY WE ARE.
COMMEMORATING READ ACROSS
AMERICA DAY WHICH WILL BE
CELEBRATED. ON THIS FRIDAY.
MARCH TO SECOND.
I IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO I ENCOURAGE
YOU. OUGHT TO FIND TIME TO READ
WITH SOME STUDENTS FOR READ
ACROSS AMERICA DAY. THEY'LL BE
STUDENTS IN THE CAPITAL TODAY
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING. IN THAT
PROGRAM AND ALSO A TOUR OF THE
CAPITOL. AND WE KNOW THAT
READING.
IT IS GOING TO HELP OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE HELP THEM STRENGTHEN
THEIR LITERACY.
AND HELP THEM TO BE GREAT
THINKERS ARE IN THE WORLD AND
FOR THOSE REASONS TODAY. AYE
MONARCHS ARISE.
INTRODUCED HR SEVENTY EIGHT
WHICH WILL RECOGNIZE A FRIDAY AS
READ ACROSS AMERICA DAY IT IS A
NATIONAL DAY.
CELEBRATING READING AN INSPIRING
CHILDREN OF ALL AGES.
TO GET INTO A GOOD BOOK.
THIS YEAR AS ALWAYS WE
COMMEMORATE DOCTOR SEUSS'S
BIRTHDAY.
AS PART OF READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY.
I READ ACROSS AMERICA SPONSORED
BY THE NATIONAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ALONG WITH
MANY OTHERS.
OF THE LEADERS IN OUR COUNTRY
WHO CARE ABOUT LITERACY AND
YOUTH GROUPS.
THE MORE CHILDREN READ THE
BETTER THEY READ.
AND THE MORE THEY READ OUTSIDE
OF SCHOOL THE BETTER THEY WILL
DO IN SCHOOL.
THE READ ACROSS AMERICA
COMMITTEE HAS ALSO LAUNCHED
CALIFORNIA READS
TO EXPAND THE CURRENT DAY OF
READING CELEBRATION. TO A
YEARLONG PROMOTION OF READING
FOR ALL AGES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE CLEARING
FRIDAY MARCH SECOND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY AND I'D ASK THAT THE FIRST
ROLE. BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I'M CHOOSING TO SPEAK TODAY ON
READING AS TODAY.
IS A CELEBRATION OF DOCTOR
SEUSS AND MANY OF US REMEMBER UP
LEARNING TO READ WITH THOSE
BOOKS THAT RAINY THAT NOT ONLY.
HAD RAIMES IN A WONDERFUL
STORIES WHO DOESN'T REMEMBER.
THE CAT IN THE HAT ON THE RAINY
DAY BUT E TALK ABOUT READING.
THERE HAVE BEEN.
A HUGE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
COUNTRY FOR READING AND YET WE
STILL HAVE MANY STUDENTS WHO
DON'T LEARN TO READ BY THIRD
GRADE. AND WE KNOW THAT IF
STUDENTS DO NOT LEARN TO READ BY
THIRD GRADE THEIR OUTCOMES ARE
MUCH POORER THAN OTHERS.
SO FOR THE YOUNG PARENTS ON OUR
FLOOR TODAY AS THEY THINK ABOUT
HOW DO I TEACH MY CHILD TO READ
THERE'S EVERY PROGRAM OUT THERE
TO CHOOSE FROM. BUT THE SIMPLEST
WAY TO CHOOSE TO TEACH YOUR
CHILD TO READ IS SIMPLY BY
READING TO THEM. WHEN YOU READ
TO THEM WHEN YOU SING TO THEM
AND YOU TALK TO THEM WHICH IS
ACTUALLY THE CAMPAIGN FIRST
FIRST FIVE THAT IS HOW YOUR
CHILDREN LEARN TO READ MY OWN
CHILDREN LEARN TO READ BEFORE
KINDERGARTEN. AND IT'S BECAUSE I
SIMPLY READ TO THEM SAYING TO
THEM AND WE LISTEN TO MUSIC SO
READ READ READ. HAVE A GREAT
DAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I JUST
WANTED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION I THINK BECOMING
A FATHER YOU KNOW READING HAS
ALWAYS BEEN IMPORTANT BUT IT
BECOMES.
SO MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPORTANT ONCE YOU BECOME A
PARENT BECAUSE AS MY COLLEAGUE
AT COLLEGE MOURNS COUNTY WAS
TALKING ABOUT FIRST LIVE AS
CAMPAIGN. AND IT'S LIKE EVERY
PBS.
EVERYTHING ON PBS YOU YOU KNOW
THE WORDS TO EVERY SONG I YOU
KNOW EVERY SHOW THAT THAT'S ON
AND SO YOU HAVE FIRST FIVE WHO
DO THE COMMERCIALS TALK READ
SEEING. IT CHANGES EVERYTHING
AND SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE REALLY ENGAGE OUR YOUNG
KIDS.
AN ARC IN OUR TO WE WE ENGAGE
OUR CHILDREN ESPECIALLY IN
READING BECAUSE DEVELOPMENTALLY
IS SO IMPORTANT MAKE SUCH A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIFE AND WE IF
WE WANT TO HAVE. A BETTER STATE
A BETTER COUNTRY IT'S REALLY ON
US AS PARENTS TO ENGAGE OUR KIDS
AND READ TO THEM SO I REALLY
SUPPORT THIS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YEAH I JUST REAL QUICKLY I'M
VERY THANKFUL FOR THIS DAY EVER
SINCE THE YEAR ABOUT NINETEEN
NINETY NINE WHEN I WAS ELECTED
TO. OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I PARTICIPATED IN THIS EVENT.
AND THE BOOK I CHOSE WAS BOX AND
SOCKS.
AND HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS WE WERE NOT.
AND.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT READING
IS ALSO VALUABLE AND IT IS THE
KEY.
TO SUCCESS FOR THOSE WHO HAVE SO
VERY LITTLE. IT IS A WAY TO
CLIMB OUT IN A VERY THANKFUL
THAT WE'RE ABLE. TO CELEBRATE
THIS
AND THERE'S ONE PAGE FROM THIS
FOX IN SOCKS.
THAT HOUSE NEW APPLICATION FOR
ME.
AND THIS IS HOW IT READS.
PLEASE SIR I DON'T LIKE THIS
TRUCK SIR MY TONGUE IS A QUICK
OR SLICK SIR AND THAT CERTAINLY
APPLIES TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SEEN NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
THIS FIRST ROLE AS BEING OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
ISRAEL IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE SIDE OF ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IF YOU
CAN READ THANK A TEACHER.
AND WE HAVE A TEACHER HERE TODAY
AT A LEADER THAT IS.
.
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ERIC HEINZ
WITH SOME OF THE CTA STATUS HERE
TO RECOGNIZE READ ACROSS AMERICA
TODAY.
WE GIVE THEM A HAND
MEMBERS ITEMS SIX AND SEVEN
WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM A.. S. C. R.
NINETY FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO TEEN DATING
VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL
ATTENTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER LET
ALONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
YESTERDAY WAS THE LAST DAY OF
FEBRUARY AND TODAY AND
PRESENTING. S. C. R. NINETY FOUR
WHICH RECOGNIZES FEBRUARY TWENTY
TEEN AS TEEN DATING VIOLENCE
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MONTH.
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE IMPACTING YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND CUTS ACROSS ALL
SEGMENTS OF OUR POPULATION.
ACCORDING TO THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
NEARLY ONE OF TEN HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN PHYSICALLY
ABUSED BY A BOYFRIEND OR
GIRLFRIEND IN THE PAST YEAR.
VICTIMS OF DATING VIOLENCE ARE
AT A HIGHER RISK OF FAILING
SCHOOL.
DRUG AND ALCOHOL USE TEEN
PREGNANCY AND EVEN CONSIDERING
ATTEMPTING SUICIDE.
SPECIFICALLY IN MY DISTRICT WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL NONPROFIT
CALLED WHAT IS LOVE.
THEIR MISSION IS TO AND
RELATIONSHIP VIOLENCE IN OUR
SCHOOLS BY TEACHING TEENS ABOUT
HEALTHY DATING.
THROUGH PARENT EMPOWERMENT.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
CLASSROOM CURRICULUM.
BY RECOGNIZING FEDERATES WENY
EIGHTEEN AS TEEN DATING VIOLENCE
AWARENESS MONTH WE EMPOWER
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND SHED LIGHT ON THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS ISSUE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE VOTE ON
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FOUR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S.
R..
GIVES ME FE ARE NINETY FOUR AND
SOME OF US MAY ALREADY KNOW ONE
IN FOR YOUNG ADULTS REPORT
DATING ABUSE EACH YEAR. LET ME
REPEAT THAT ONE IN FOUR. YOUNG
ADULTS REPORT ABUSE EACH YEAR.
WHEN I LOOK AROUND THIS ROOM I
KNOW MANY OF US ARE PARENTS.
AND I KNOW THAT NOT A SINGLE ONE
OF US COULD EVEN IMAGINE THE
THOUGHT OF OUR OWN KIDS HAVING
TO INDOOR. ANY TYPE OF ABUSE
HOWEVER IF WE DON'T CONTINUE TO
EDUCATE OUR YOUTH ABOUT WHAT
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS LOOK LIKE.
AND FEEL LIKE OUR KIDS MAY VERY
WELL END UP BEING A PART OF THE
STATISTIC.
WITH THE HELP OF EDUCATION
LEADERS COUNSELORS AND CARING
ADULTS WE CAN FURTHER SUPPORT
OUR YOUTH OVERALL WELL BEING.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
RESOLUTION ARE AS HE ARE NINETY
FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN A FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMO WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST
ROLE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE FIRST ROW
MEMBERS AS WELL AS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MS LOW MOAN IS ASKING FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE BEEN SHOW.
OF.
MEMBERS WE HAVE BEEN JOINED BY
SOME VERY SPECIAL GUESTS TODAY.
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM
STIR RENDON'S.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO BE OF THE
REPERTOIRE TO INTRODUCE. A VERY
SPECIAL GUEST TO OUR STATE
ASSEMBLY IN OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE.
REPRESENTING. ONE OF.
CALIFORNIA IS MOST IMPORTANT
TRADING PARTNERS AND ONE OF OUR
NATION'S MOST IMPORTANT
STRATEGIC ALLIES. REPRESENTING
THE NATION OF JAPAN IS THE
CONSUL GENERAL OF JAPAN MIS
SERVED TO MUCH CO WE AMONG.
PLEASE GIVE A WARM ASSEMBLY
WELCOME
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
INTRODUCTION OF OUR CUTEST
VISITOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES I WANT
TO. REINTRODUCE ALL OF YOU TO MY
SON LUCAS WHO WAS COINCIDENTALLY
TWO YEARS OLD TODAY.
SINCE HE WAS LAST ON THE FLOOR
IS LEARN HOW TO WALK.
HOW TO TALK AND?
HE HAS THE.
STRANGER TRACTION MICROPHONES.
AND.
I KNOW IS LOOKING FORWARD TO
PLAYING WITH THE CHILDREN OF ALL
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE NEW%
PARENTS CAUCUS IT WITH THAT.
HE'S LOOKING FOR TO GET TO KNOW
ALL OF YOU THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'D LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE SOME SPECIAL GUESTS
IN THE AUDIENCE AND ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE SPOUSAL.
CAMELIA.
A BEAUTIFUL FLOWER.
OF COURSE A LOT EVER CHAMELEONS
WERE LOST A COUPLE DAYS AGO WITH
THE HAILSTORM BUT BILL BE.
BOUNCING BACK AND AS YOU MAY
KNOW SACRAMENTO IS THE KEY
MILLION CAPITAL OF THE WORLD.
CAMILLE'S ARE ARE THE AT THIS A
FLOWER OF SACRAMENTO BEAUTIFUL
AND MANY NEIGHBORHOODS AND THIS
WEEKEND WERE HUSTLIN NINETY
FOURTH ANNUAL KEY MILIEU SHOW.
DOWN A MEMORIAL AUDITORIUM A
FREE EVENT OPEN OF THE PUBLIC
THAT ALL THE SITES.
SHOWING IN THE UNITED STATES
FOR NEARLY A CENTURY OUR
VOLUNTEER THE BEEN HELPING
CELEBRATE THAT BEAUTIFUL FLOWER
AND THE UNIQUE. I CALIFORNIA
CULTURE AT THE KEY MILLION THAT
CAN THEIR SOCIETY IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HOLDS
HORTICULTURE CLASSES LECTURES
AND EXHIBITS.
THAT MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MEMBERS OF THE KEY
MILLION SOCIETY OF SACRAMENTO
TODAY IN THE CHAMBERS
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF YOUR CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR VERY
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
SPECIAL GUEST TODAY AND THAT'S
REALLY EXCITING BECAUSE ABOUT A
COUPLE OF BIRTHDAYS HERE ON THE
FLOOR. BUT YESTERDAY WE SUBMIT
CELEBRATED MY PARTNER LARRY'S
BIRTHDAY SOLARES UP IN THE
GALLEY AND I WANT YOU DAHLE
EGGMAN BIG WAIVERS BIRTHDAY AS
WELL HIS TWO BEST FRIENDS KAREN.
AND NORM ROSEN FROM UKIAH
CALIFORNIA HAPPY BIRTHDAY LARRY
.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS
THINK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY SOME OF ITS MORE
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS.
THREE SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT
HAVE BEEN NAMED TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SCHOOLS TO WATCH.
FROM ABC UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE HAVE FAIRLY INTERNATIONAL
STUDIES ACADEMY IN HAWAIIAN
GARDENS.
WE ALSO HAVE TO SCHOOLS FROM THE
PARAMOUNT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HOLIDAY OKAY THROUGH
EIGHT SCHOOL IN SOUTH GATE. AND
PARAMOUNT PARK MIDDLE SCHOOL IN
PARAMOUNT. EACH YEAR SCHOOLS TO
WATCH IDENTIFY SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ACADEMICALLY EXCELLENT SOCIALLY
EQUITABLE AND STRUCTURED FOR
SUCCESS.
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE TWO
DISTRICTS AND THEIR SCHOOLS ARE
WITH US IN THE GALLERY FROM
PARAMOUNT UNIFIED REPRESENTING
THE HOLIDAY HOLIDAY ON PARAMOUNT
PARK WE HAVE BOARD OF. EDUCATION
PRESIDENT RUTH PEREZ VICE
PRESIDENT SONYA Y. ARE AND BOARD
MEMBER AND WE SHARE ANDERSON WE
ALSO HAVE SU YOU PRESIDENT THE
ABC UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
CHRIS APODACA ABOARD MEMBER ABC
UNIFIED AND DOCTOR MARY SUE THE
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT PLEASE
WELCOME THESE GASSING GRADUATE
THEM AND THEIR STAFFS ON THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING OUT TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER
WHICH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR JACKSON
RELATIVE TO COURT REPORTERS.
THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ALL THOSE.
VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE COURT CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS A REMINDER THAT TODAY IS
THE LAST DAY TO FILE. YOUR
STATEMENT OF ECONOMIC INTEREST
FORMS FORM SEVEN HUNDRED MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO THE CITY CLERK TO
THE CHIEF CLERK ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY SIX BY FIVE PM.
THIS DEADLINE IS FOR MEMBERS
ONLY DESIGNATED STAFF MUST FILE
BY APRIL SECOND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS MARCH SECOND NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY MARCH FIFTH FLOOR SESSION
AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSING RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING IN
HERE THERE HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
CALDERON MOVES TO MISTER DALLI
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY MARCH
FIFTH AT ONE PM THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED